tell you i'm quarter welsh by the way no
you're not i'm one of your people no
you're not twenty five percent
you're not one of me my grandfather i
refuse i refuse to believe it
i reject your family name is pew p-u-g-a
oh god that is actually wild
i'm lucky we're the same you're
basically related this is what happens
when you're
straight from the path of wales you
become a christian
you escape you become a cultural
approach
you become chris broad if you stray from
the pair
how did you feel going to that royal
welsh city
well i think it's awesome you know
because the you know unlike japanese
like welsh culture
got like [ __ ] obliterated by the
english they pretty much they made it
like almost illegal to speak welsh in
wales
for a very long time you get punished if
you spoke well so i you know
when there's anything kind of even
remotely well you're quite proud because
i'm like
nobody gives a [ __ ] so it's awesome who
gives a [ __ ] yeah because it's so weird
because
normally when people think of whales
they just think of like the uk in
general
it's like it is very difficult anyway so
yeah you know we still have greg's we
still have betfred
depressing [ __ ] but like the houses look
very different most of the time
depending on where you go
you know i mean people forget that
whales have just their own language yeah
yeah
people some people think it's a city in
england for [ __ ] sake which is
depressing
because files is my city well i think
there was a quiz that they asked like
americans
about famous english towns and where
they kept listing whales as a city
some people in this survey oh no you
know i mean like
it doesn't happen in scotland everyone
knows scotland everyone knows ireland
because everyone in [ __ ] america
insists they're irish
yeah exactly so it doesn't happen but
like that nobody nobody's well she
nobody gives a [ __ ]
about it so it's really good to see what
someone does yeah yeah the only time i
ever got any
conversation about it was then people
watched the [ __ ] crown and they were
like oh he spoke
that funny language that you speak in
that in the third season i'm like
thanks yeah it got like one episode they
[ __ ] off and they never spoke about it
again
it was like one of the most depressing
episodes it's very [ __ ] depressing
it's weird it's weird that's pretty it's
pretty [ __ ] tragic
we have a prince of wales it doesn't
come to [ __ ] whales
i mean you must be in the top 10 most
successful welsh people in the world
[Laughter]
i mean i don't know any other welshman
catherine zeta-jones you know
christian bale christian bale gareth
male sorry
chris oh christian bale is yeah but he's
like a weird kind of uh
i think he's well is he welsh i think he
is i think he's born in wales but raised
in london
anthony hopkins hopkins christopher
alice the guy who plays lucifer
oh really he's walsh from cars you're up
there with them see all these people
yes the hopkins oscar-winning actor and
c-dog v8 member of the trash station
podcast
[Laughter]
i think he speaks well i think so oh
because he's always tweeting a lot does
he follow you on twitter that's the goal
i thought
when i get verified when you get
verified all right
you earned it